mais
alors tout
l'ouverture du procès ans de la marque
et à palerme 355 prévenu ce 90 chefs
d'accusation mais peu de gros bonnets
les américains à perplexe et embarrassé
devant l'ampleur de la fraude électorale
aux philippines washington suggère
maintenant aux deux adversaires de
travailler ensemble
le froid bien installé sur la france il
faisait moins 18 ce matin en auvergne le
moscou paris joue les z'omni madame
monsieur bonsoir l'état de siège 2000
positionne alerte maximum des
automitrailleuses qui prennent position
des journalistes débarqué du monde
entier une population qui retient son
souffle
cela ne se peut l'erm en italie où vient
de s'ouvrir le procès de la mafia au
banc des accusés enfermés dans des cages
blindés 355 personnes 110 900 en fuite
l'acte d'accusation comporte plus de
8000 pages le procès devrait durer
longtemps très longtemps
nous en étions donc aujourd'hui auprès
limitait aux préliminaires le climat sur
place avec un travail est spécial victor
ramos chef du clan des colonies qu'il
est en prison depuis une dizaine
d'années mais il n'a jamais cessé de
diriger son clan et d'ordonner
l'exécution de dizaines de policiers
magistrats
c'est ça qui est important c'est qu'on a
installé dans ses cages blindés les
chefs de la mafia
même si parmi les 119 accusés en fuite
il est encore les grécos dont michele
gréco celui qu'on appelle le pape que
soit le verdict de ce procès qui
pourrait durer un an
on aura la possibilité de comprendre
l'exécution de 95 policiers magistrats
et en politiques locaux on comprendra
comment fonctionne la mafia comment elle
est structurée et comment elle investit
les bénéfices du trafic de la drogue
assiste à ce procès francesco rosi
auteur de nombreux films sur la
criminalité organisée en italie
je ne fais pas d illusions sur le fait
qu'un procès même un procès important
qu'on nous celui ci puisse nous
débarrasser de la mafia la mafia c'est
un phénomène qui touche à la société à
l' organisation de la société qui touche
la culture d'un peuple qui touche
l'histoire francesco rosi a certainement
raison
ce n'est pas avec un procès aussi
important soit-il qu'on pourra éliminer
la mafia mais il ne faudrait pas
exagérer dans un sens négatif
le fait même qu'on ait réussi à
organiser le procès de 474 mafiosi est
déjà un événement
inimaginable il ya encore deux ou trois
ans alors pourquoi n'y aurait-il pas
dans les prochaines années d'autres
repentis à par tommaso bouchette
d'autres arrestations et d'autres procès
contre la mafia
effectivement ce procès il était
inconcevable il y a quelques années on
doit donc à la ténacité à l'entêtement
d'une poignée de juges courageux qui est
consacré leur vie à la lutte contre la
mafia certains sont morts abattus en
pleine rue comme par exemple le
procureur costa ou comme le chef du
parquet jean ici ceux qui ont survécu
ceux qui ont poursuivi la tâche ont vu
leur vie complètement bouleversée par
leur enquête c'est le cas du juge
giovanni falcone et le grand ordonnateur
de ce procès voici son portrait brossé
par nos confrères qu'il a souvent
rencontré c'est fabrizio calvi c'est un
petit homme affable d'isère qui n'a
pratiquement plus de plus de vie privée
autour de lui gravitent en permanence
une trentaine de carabinier enfin
carabiniers donc 30 pour se relayer
chaque fois qu'il se déplace c'est donc
en voiture blindée il ya des hommes
d'escort il ya trois ou de voitures
neuves et devant lui chaque fois qu'il
va voir sa fiancée
tout le quartier
es tu au courant puisque le quartier
quadrillé quand il se baigne on dit
qu'il ya des vedettes de carabinier qui
patrouille au large de même ses
dernières vacances il les a pris dans
l'île du diable italienne qui est l'asie
n'a requis une petite île entre la corse
et la sardaigne
battu par les vents et la mère et où il
ya installé un super pénitencier parce
qu'on ne veut pas servir de cette île
qui vit comme ça depuis cinq ans et il
vit comme ça depuis cinq ans en sachant
en ayant une seule certitude c'est que
la retraite c'est impossible pour lui
c'est à dire la retraite dans tous les
sens du terme il n'aura jamais sa
retraite il ne peut pas faire marche
arrière c'est impossible il va mourir
il va mourir il a la certitude non mais
on sent bien qu'il a cette certitude il
sait très bien que quand la mafia veut
avoir la peau d'un juge de toute manière
laura et elle l'a bien montré en
assassinant le malheureux conciliaire et
banco qui m'est chère qui j'ai dédié ce
livre parce qu'ils m'avaient beaucoup
peiné qui est mort donc se concilier ray
avec ces cinq hommes d'escort après
l'explosion d'une voiture piégée
renfermant 50 kg de tnt donc quand la
mafia veut vraiment la fonte d'un juge n
la wii si vous vous intéressez à ce
procès si vous voulez comprendre la
manière dont tu agis la mafia je vous
engage à lire ce livre de fabrizio calvi
c'est un vous allez voir maintenant
voilà et c'était remarquable d'une
remarquable somme qui permet donc de
comprendre la manière dont fonctionne la
nora bhl société il est paru chez
hachette et fabrizio calvi sera l'invité
de daniel leconte dans le tout dernier
journal nous environs de 23 heures pour
revenir donc sur ce procès de la mafia
et puis l'italie toujours et toujours le
meurtre organisé mais il s'agit cette
fois de terrorisme avec l'assassinât de
l'ancien maire de florence a battu tout
à l'heure par un commando c'est un
meurtre qui était revendiqué par les
brigades rouges le point avec sur place
à correspondante de l' agence
france-presse
au téléphone
sa vitalité proche de qualité d'apprenti
accompagné en italie l'ouverture du
premier procès une histoire contre la
mafia
c'est à 1200 km de là dans la paisible
florence koné pour agonisante haute à
nouveau frappé terrorisme encore avec
peut-être du nouveau dans l'enquêté sur
les derniers attentats mais à paris
cette fois vous savez qu'on ait
découvert des armes dans une voiture
abandonnée c'était il ya trois jours
dans la capitale
eh bien ces armes paraissent semblables
à d'autres armes utilisées au cours
d'attentats à vienne et à l'autre une
grosse blague est un doux rêve ou
l'illustration d'un embarras politique
considérable l'histoire fera son show
aux philippines après la suggestion
américaine qui propose aux deux
adversaires sert dinan marcos et corazon
aquino de travailler ensemble ce qui
semble vous en conviendrez bien peu
probable
l'embarras en tout cas est évident au
lendemain d'élections de plus en plus
clairement frauduleuse dans ce pays et
alors que le président le rôle du
président marcos est de plus en plus
clairement contestée y compris et
compris par ceux qui devaient vérifier
la régularité du scrutin
le poids sur place avec philippe lefait
et la réaction aux états unis avec notre
correspondant à washington
jacquat bouchard c'est dans la rue que
se joue désormais les élections
philippines une manifestation a réuni
cet après midi devant l'assemblée
nationale à manille des milliers de
supporters de corée qui nous ils crient
contre la fraude dénonce une assemblée
qui doit prononcer les résultats
officiels et qui est à la botte de
ferdinand marcos
la foule jettent des cailloux sur les
députés les membres du service d'ordre
qui se forcent encore à y croire
à cinq kilomètres de là correa qui nous
redit l'essentiel de sa tactique
s'il vous plaît monsieur marcos donner
la présidence au peuple c'est au cours
des manifestations qui ont suivi le
passage de coria kino dans le quartier d
affaires qu un attentat a été commis
un tueur non identifié a tiré dans la
foule et tué un partisan de madame akino
quant aux résultats ils ne veulent plus
rien dire
en quittant manie ce matin les
observateurs américains indiqué que le
processus électoral a été
irrémédiablement compromis le chef de la
mission américaine le sénateur lugar
conclut et ronald reagan pourrait
prendre des décisions essentielles si
les résultats ne sont pas honnêtes
le processus est enclenché quelques
heures plus tard la maison blanche prend
parti le président marcos et sa rivale
madame aquino devraient travailler
ensemble
il permettrait ainsi la formation d'un
gouvernement stable qui mettrait en
oeuvre des réformes sans violence cette
déclaration émane du porte parole de la
maison blanche larry spx elle traduit un
certain désarroi du côté américain
après des élections présidentielles
philippines entaché de fraudes massives
en fait washington redoute tout autant
une victoire de monsieur marcos qu'un
succès de corazon aquino
dans le premier cas il en résulterait à
coup sûr une exaspération des opposants
pouvant déboucher sur les pires
désordres voir la guerre civile la
seconde hypothèse
une victoire de mode mcqueen au risque
de braquer l'armée et d'accélérer un
processus de dictature pure et simple
les états unis essaient donc de naviguer
tant bien que mal entre ces deux
redoutables écueil en haïti le général
dans fille qui préside le conseil de
gouvernement vient d'annoncer des
élections présidentielle au suffrage
universel direct c'est une très bonne
nouvelle dans ce pays privé de liberté
depuis 29 ans même si le communiqué du
gouvernement ne prévoit aucune date pour
l'instant pour ces élections
il expose en revanche quelques grands
principes démocratiques fondées sur le
respect des droits de l'homme la liberté
de la presse l'existence de syndicats
libres et de parti politique structuré
par ailleurs l'une des
dernière décision du nouveau
gouvernement c'est la dissolution
officielle des tontons macoutes cette
milice de 300000 personnes dont 25 mille
paramilitaires qui étaient vouées à la
famille duvalier ses tontons macoutes
qui se sont illustrés dans la férocité
tout au long des dernières années qui
sont depuis quelques jours la cible de
la population regardez ce reportage que
vient de nous faire parvenir notre
envoyé spécial jacques doigts c'est en
haïti où la banlieue sud de port au
prince n'a pas échappé au pillage de ce
dernier week-end les premières visées
ont été les maisons des tontons macoutes
ses miliciens de l'ancien régime
responsable des basses oeuvres du
président à vie 50 miliciens étaient
massacrés 300 personnes blessées
la maison de cet homme est encerclée par
une foule hurlante lui a laissé son
uniforme pour sa défense il prétend
qu'il n'a jamais été ma coûte mais
simplement policiers
pourtant il crève il transpire la peur
duvalier l'abandonner à son sort
policiers ou macoutes
ça n'est plus la question dehors son cas
est déjà réglé il n'y a qu'une sentence
depuis le départ de baby da pour la
femme du policier qui s'effondre c'est
sûr il va mourir elle c'est ce qu'on a
fait aux autres dans son quartier
ceux qui ont été attrapés sont morts
sous les jets de pierres tous les coups
de bâton
aujourd'hui la chance est rentré dans la
maison les militaires sont arrivés par
hasard et se sont interposés c'est sous
leur protection que le flic de duvalier
a pu échapper à la foule devant les
uniformes les manifestants ont baissé
leurs bâtons pour regarder partir le
tortionnaire d'hier qui emmène toute sa
famille les militaires ne le quitteront
qu'à la caserne où il sera interrogé le
policier partir la foule s'en prendra à
sa maison elle n'aura pas tout perdu
et pour assouvir sa haine tranquille
profonde les effets personnels du
mobilier
il ne reste rien oui pendant ce temps là
l'ex président à vie jean claude
duvalier toujours à talloires en haute
savoie dans la tente d'un lieu d'exil
officiel la france ne souhaite pas le
conserver trop longtemps sur son sol son
passage d'ailleurs provoque toujours des
manifestations vous le voyez ici c'était
aujourd'hui à talloires où les voisins
forcé de baby doc et est venu marquer
leur hostilité à l'ancien dictateur
cet après midi à talloires haute-savoie
où réside donc baby doc en la ans dans
la tente à nouveau point de chute
on l'appelle le pont aux espions c'est
un immense ouvrage qui relie le secteur
américain de berlin ouest à l'allemagne
de l'est
et cela que suivant un cérémonial très
précis se font les échanges entre
espions de l'est espionne ouest comme au
cinéma avec un nouvel échange demain
l'ouest libérera cinq agents l'est en
libérera 4 ajoutant tholot le fameux
dissidents anatolie chtcharansky sont
les conditions de cet échange les
précisions de michel meyer habib
surveillance militaire depuis le ciel un
pont sur un fleuve gelé la raven le
calme avant un déchaînement médiatique
qui a déjà transformé deviner car brute
que le pont des espions en lieu de
rendez vous mondial de la presse
occidentale
certains cameramen et photographes font
le pied de grue depuis près d'une
semaine les télévisions américaines
diffusaient en direct les images d'un
écran gestion qui ne fait plus de doute
en clair les négociateurs richard de
bottes l'ambassadeur des états unis à
bonn et wolfgang voigt avocat à
berlin-est ont bien travaillé
le marché est conclu
le lieu et l'heure fixée moscou libérera
le dissident soviétique chtcharansky
c'est confirmé c'est sûr il prendra
directement un avion sur la base
militaire de berlin templeuve en
direction de francfort à francfort il
montera dans un avion de la compagnie
israélienne el al à destination de tel
aviv la guerre oubliée entre l'iran et
l'irak avec une nouvelle offensive
iranienne au sud de la ligne de front
elle a permis aux troupes de téhéran de
franchir la frontière irakienne en
traversant le détroit du châtel arabe
c'est la première fois que les iraniens
mettent ainsi le pied en territoire
irakien
dans ce secteur en tout cas depuis le
début de la guerre c'était en 1981 il ya
déjà cinq ans cette percée été admise et
à bagdad où l'on s'efforce toutefois de
minimiser son importance
la mort mystérieuse d'un militant de
solidarité dans le sud de la pologne il
été retrouvée inanimée avec une fracture
du crâne devant un hôtel où il devait
participer à une messe pour la patrie
donc organisé par solidarité
il avait été arrêté et interné en
plusieurs occasions la politique ont
ralenti après les petites phrases du
week-end un week-end consacré
essentiellement à l'opposition puisque
raymond barre était au club de la presse
d'europe numéro un et jacques chirac
l'invité de 7 sur 7 sur tf1
aujourd'hui laurent fabius était quant à
lui dans le nord de la france le premier
ministre qui a renouvelé son appel aux
électeurs qui ne sont pas forcément
socialiste il tenait aussi pris de
nouveau au groupe hersant que les
français sachent qu actuellement un gros
d'une extraordinaire puissance est en
train de développer son emprise qu'il a
déjà rendez-vous dans la prochaine
assemblée nationale avec vingt députés
qui sont ses salariés que la seule borne
mise à son pouvoir
c'est la loi et la volonté que les
socialistes ont adopté en ce qui le
concerne et que si cette loi est cette
volonté était pas fou et qu'il n'y
aurait plus d'obstacle à ce que ce
monopole viennent manger la totalité de
la presse française
la croissance un peu ralenti pour
l'économie française en 1985 d'après les
chiffres que vient de publier l'institut
de la statistique
cette croissance a été de 1 3% l'an
dernier contre 1 9% en 1984 alors raison
de cet essoufflement et mai s'explique
notamment par une petite faiblesse sur
les exportations un double échec pour
les gangsters dans le sud de la france
avec 2 attaque manquée contre des
faucons de transport de fond c'était à
marseille et à aix-en-provence
vous avez aussi la découverte da
souterrain par lequel les malfaiteurs
pensait pénétrer dans les locaux d'une
société de convoyage mai à montpellier
cette fois le reportage de thierry calme
est sur place et deux ligues bachofen
attaquer les convoyeurs de fonds de la
société protect val ça ne paye plus ce
matin à marseille deux attaques deux
échecs le quartier de la rose dans la
matinée les gangsters attendent le
fourgon qui apporte des fonds à cette
agence de la caisse d'epargne l'employé
de protec valve sort du fourgon
les malfaiteurs ouvrent le feu et le
manque de peu depuis le fourgon la
riposte est immédiate
les gangsters s'enfuit sous un feu
nourri ils repartent à pied bredouilles
les clients dans ce café sont aux
premières loges
mais ils ne se souviennent de rien
deuxième échec
tôt ce matin vers 6h30 un poids lourd a
tenté d'intercepter un fourgon semblable
à celui ci qui rentrait au siège de la
maison protect valent aux milles près
d'aix scénario classique
le fort vent a basculé dans le fossé les
gangsters descendu du poids lourds ouvre
le feu de l'intérieur du fourgon
renverser les employés riposte les
gangsters s'enfuit les poches vides
les nombreuses et fructueuses agressions
commises contre cette société avait été
minutieusement organisée par les
gangsters
aujourd'hui il semble avoir agi avec
moins de méthodes plus de précipitations
résultat pas un seul centime de butin un
procès de l'autodéfense à lyon cela nous
ramène au mois d'octobre 1982 un jeune
algérien de 16 ans est tuée de deux
coups de carabine 22 long rifle par un
jeune homme de 20 ans quand il cherchait
voler la voiture un procès qui se
déroule dans une ambiance très
particulière en raison d'une campagne de
sensibilisation organisée par les amis
de la victime sur place
agnès poirier et jean corneille il est
battu et wiley chichi volontairement
tout s'est passé tellement vite
nicolas bardelli meurtrier à 20 ans
avaient fusé aujourd'hui d'être filmé le
28 octobre 82 il a tiré cinq fois avec
une carabine 22 long rifle
du haut de son balcon sur deux jeunes
gens qui étaient affirme-t-il en train
de voler sa bmw wade chichis un jeune
lycéen de 18 ans est tué sur le coup
après six mois de prison préventive
nicolas bardelli libéré aussitôt la
famille de la victime ses amis se
mobilisent au sein d'une association des
familles des victimes des crimes
racistes et sécuritaire aujourd'hui à
travers bardelli c'est en quelque sorte
l'autodéfense que l'on juge la côte et
nicolas bardelli défendu par maître
garot de l'autre la famille de wade à
chichis s'est constituée partie civile
ses amis ses camarades de classe dans
lyon actuellement sur les murs cette
question que vaut la vie de wahid à
chichis pour nicolas bardelli qui a
choisi il ya 80 de faire justice
lui-même sa voiture comptait plus que
tout
les tests médicaux sont à la mode il
s'agit de ces flacons de ces plaquettes
qui permettent de savoir si on a la
luminosité attend un bébé sans passer
par les services de laboratoire avec
quand même bien des interrogations sur
la fiabilité sont l'efficacité de ces
produits
mais ce n'est pas fini de nouveaux tests
pourraient maintenant être commercialisé
libyen pourrait être commercialisé en
france une sorte de laboratoire en kit
venue des états unis mais qui vous allez
le voir aux encore pour le moment plus
d'interrogations qu'il n'apporte
véritablement de réponse le point donc
avec lucie soboul et bruno carette une
porte blindée un code d'entrée les
progrès de la biologie sont bien
protégés dans ce laboratoire
ultramoderne des biologistes essaye de
développer le marché des tests de
diagnostic rapide
leur principe est connu et utilisé
depuis longtemps il s'agit de révéler la
présence d'une substance bactéries virus
aux hormones grâce à une petite bande de
papier sur laquelle se trouve déjà un
réactif
quelques gouttes d'uriné ou de sang une
demi-heure d'attentes une dernière
manipulation l'apparition d'une couleur
bleue indique un résultat positif grâce
à cette technique quelques tests sont
déjà commercialisés en france
diagnostic de grossesse ou surveillance
de la glycémie pour les diabétiques
d'autres devraient les rejoindre
surveillance de l'ovulation dépistage du
produit responsable d'une allergie ou
encore diagnostic des maladies
infectieuses ou des maladies
sexuellement transmissibles
ça correspond à une nouvelle mentalité
nous au niveau par exemple de la qualité
de la vie au niveau de l'hygiène
alimentaire au niveau par exemple du
sport il en est de même par exemple au
niveau d'un certain nombre d'individus
qui voudront contrôler leur taux de
cholestérol ou d'un certain nombre de
paramètres qui seront les signes d'une
bonne santé d'une bonne hygiène
alimentaire
pourtant on n'en est pas encore là si
certains test d'auto surveillance sont à
la portée de tous les autres sont plus
délicats à manier car ils se font sur le
sang ils devront donc être réservée aux
médecins qui veulent obtenir un résultat
immédiat mais là les biologie
sont plus d'accord ils sont les seuls en
france avant le droit de pratiquer des
analyses médicales ce qu'on veut faire
croire dans cette affaire c'est que ce
genre de tests qui sont des tests
d'orientation deviendrai des analystes
jeudi que ce ne sont pas des années dit
parce que ces analyses nous les faisons
et elles sont soumises au contrôle
ce sont des tests d'orientation est tout
à fait d'accord pour que le médecin
puisse avoir une orientation est resté
le seul compromis serait donc de
considérer ces tests comme une simple
orientation avant le diagnostic il ne
serait utilisé qu'en cas d'urgence ou
dans les endroits isolés un rapport
ministériel vient de recommander la plus
grande prudence car leur fiabilité leur
efficacité reste à prouver
on est donc encore loin de voir leur
emploi se généraliser
depuis hier nous sommes dans l'année du
tigre c'est à dire la nouvelle année
version astrologie chinoise c'est donc
le nouvel an pour des centaines de
milliers d'asiatiques qui habite
maintenant la france et qu'ils ont donc
fêté hier en famille ou dans la rue
l'occasion aussi de vous raconter pour
nous de vous raconter une histoire celle
de ce breton devenu l'un des principaux
producteurs de pâtes et impériaux le
monsieur s'appelle jean-pierre le roux
et ses pattes et s'appelle tout
bonnement les pattes et luang
le reportage à consommer avec des
baguettes de jean-pierre dubois et
massat et marcel martin on connaît le
calvaire breton l'artichaut et le chou
fleur breton la crêpe bretonne mais
envie que dans le finistère on y ajoute
maintenant la galette de riz pour faire
le même breton plus connu sous son noble
nom de pâté impérial à l'origine de
cette révolution gastronomique bund sous
une laotienne bretonne d'adoption avec
son mari jean pierre leroux en 84 il
décide de se lancer dans la fabrication
de nems et de créer leur entreprise la
société nuance
cela semble un peu par feu lui surtout
sans argent mais la municipalité dans
vie décide quand même de leur prêter un
million de francs
nous avons été le détonateur celui qui
au départ avons dit nous avons confiance
en jean pierre leroux et nous allons
l'aider à s'installer et partant de là
bien sûr il a trouvé les partenaires et
les banques
elle dit même conduit ont fait confiance
résultat une usine moderne et surtout 20
emplois créés pour les nems certains
produits comme ses cheveux d'ange bienne
de thaïlande mais la majorité provient
de la région comme les carottes ou le
port pour fabriquer industriellement les
nems
il a fallu inventer cette chaîne unique
au monde 10 mm en sortent chaque jour
le succès a été immédiat une surprise
pour un produit pas vraiment locale
c'est pas parce que les bretons qu'on ne
peut pas faire de l'exotisme et c'est
peut-être un petit peu le tour des des
bretons c'est de vouloir produire breton
et nous sait pas c'est parce qu'on veut
faire on veut produire en bretagne ça
c'est important
ses principaux clients les grandes
surfaces mais déjà jean-pierre leur
ouvre regarde vers l'étranger il vient
même de signer un accord avec la marine
américaine objectif 20 mm par jour fin
86 mais pour réussir il faut savoir se
diversifier alors books ou préparent
déjà de nouvelles recettes
ce un produit qui vont sortir aussi
d'ordre de moi ça c'est le cas d'attaqué
le pôle écuries lateulade soja et le riz
cantonais et en exclusivité pour antenne
2 voici le seul name authentique membres
dont le même à la crau belle que de week
end pluvieux de vacances mouillé ou de
mercredi glace est sauvé par une simple
petite boîte plein de trucs qu'on colle
ça s'appelle une maquette on achète
c'est en général pour les enfants mais
c'est quand même le papa qui les
montrent ce qui est quand même très
hypocrite vous l'admettrez et bien salon
de la maquette et du modélisme se tient
en ce moment à paris
c'est jusqu'au 16 février alors patrick
esther et patrick à ce club
ils sont allés à rêver un instant au bon
papa qui vous ait affirmé que la
maquette permet de réaliser ses rêves
les plus secrets
sûrement pas l'auteur de ce modèle
réalisant d'allumettes et réplique
exacte de la cellule qu'il occupe à la
prison de la santé
au total ils sont une trentaine de
prisonniers qui passent leur temps
derrière les barreaux à construire de
paisibles église ou une version
supplémentaire de la tour eiffel
décidément les enfants peuvent regarder
rêver mais le monde du modèle réduit est
affaire de grandes personnes
ces avions représentent une petite
fortune en travail mais aussi en argent
puisqu'il coûte l'équivalent d'une
voiture d'occasion guerre pour les
enfants également ses fusée à moteurs à
poudre longtemps interdite en france
elles sont de nouveau apporté des états
unis 300 francs le bon dans les nuages
abordable les trains south avait depuis
longtemps n'appartiennent qu'aux garçons
que le soir de noël dès le lendemain
c'est papa qui prend tout en charge
et c'est tant mieux puisque c'est le co
motifs valent entre trois et huit mille
francs je vous laisse imaginer le prix
total de ce train destiné aux jardins
évolutions technologiques obligent les
plus mordus pilotes avec l'aide de
l'ordinateur
même si le réseau
minuscule n'en a pas réellement besoin
quant aux soldats de plomb n'en parlons
pas je vous ai dit il n'y en a que pour
les adultes
il se vend chaque jour une centaine de
ces figurines dernières nouveautés on
disait jusqu'ici que pour réaliser des
maquettes il fait particulièrement
patient et méticuleux
alors ce fabricant a eu l'idée de mettre
dans une boîte absolument tout ce qu'il
faut y compris la colle et les tours de
vis pour assembler un modèle réduit
en moins de deux heures et ça fonctionne
on l'appelle le moscou paris c'est un
vent glacé qui nous vient de sibérie qui
fait trembler la france - 18 mai -18 ce
matin en auvergne et surtout nice et
même ajaccio transformé en station de
sports d'hiver laurent boussier oui et
un an après les records de froid de
janvier 85 nice et la côte d'azur sont
donc à nouveau sous la neige la nuit
dernière il est tombé entre 10 et 15
centimètres de neige
et ce matin la circulation était
difficile sur tout le littoral en corse
est à peu près la même chose surtout
ajaccio où les chutes de neige se sont
poursuivis une grande partie de la
journée les bateaux les oranges et les
routes sont couverts d'un manteau blanc
qui compte tenu du froid devrait tenir
au moins pendant quelques jours et puis
cette image cette image de cet
agrandissement de la photo satellite où
l'on peut voir choses assez inhabituel
de la neige sur toute la bretagne ouest
ces traces ne sont pas des nuages c'est
de la neige des traces de neige sur
toute la le sud de la bretagne c'est
assez inhabituel cette neige est
également présente sur toutes les
pyrénées il y en a un peu plus sur les
pyrénées c'est normal
deux traces de neige sur les pyrénées et
sur la bretagne l'envoyé de la neige sur
les pyrénées de la neige sur la bretagne
de la neige encore de la neige
à nice des endroits où il est assez
inhabituel j'aimerais pouvoir vous dire
que ça va cesser mais ça n'est pas vrai
regardez la photo satellite la vraie la
grande celle ci avec toujours cet
anticyclone qui dirige doucement
doléances qui vient en droite ligne de
sibérie pratiquement c'est pour ça qu'il
est si froid ait pris cette dépression
la sur l'italie et puis sur le golfe de
gênes qui fait revenir ces nuages par
l'ess des retours d'est tous nos
malheurs pour le moment vienne 2 laisse
regarder la carte du temps prévu pour
demain toujours une france coupée en
deux avec s'est tenu des températures
très froides - 14
cette nuit dans le centre - 12 dans
l'est - 10 entre tours et angers - 11
entre agen et toulouse et températures
très froides et puis dans la journée
donc toujours un temps gris nuageux avec
quelques rares chutes de neige sur l'est
des alpes sur toute la moitié est du
pays
un temps clair et très ensoleillé après
la dissipation des brouillards matinaux
sur toute la moitié ouest
attention le vent le mistral et
tramontane reste très fort en
méditerranée côté températures elles
sont stationnaires si l'on peut dire
avec toujours moins 10 degrés dans
l'extrême est et puis plus de à à à
brest il ya les températures sont
positives que sur le littoral de
l'atlantique sur la moitié sud de -7 à
clermont ferrand
jusqu'à quand même plus
5 6 degrés en corse toujours m'enfin +5
+6° ça n'est pas grand chose notre
agenda pour terminer dès qu'il arrive
s'il arrive demain mardi 11 février le
soleil se lève à 8h08 se couche à 18h03
nous fait quatre minutes de soleil en
plus c'est la 5
félix mais c'est aussi le mardi gras et
présente les principales informations à
retenir de ce journal hormis le froid
d'abord l'ouverture du procès géant de
la mafia palerme 355 prévenu 90 chefs
d'accusation
et puis les américains qui sont bien
embarrassés devant l'ampleur de la
fraude électorale aux philippines
tout à l'heure washington a suggéré aux
deux a dit aux deux adversaires de
travailler ensemble ce qui est quand
même tout à fait improbable
voilà dernier journal avec daniel
leconte aux environs de 23 heures à 3
heures fac et puis demain à 6h45
télématin quant à moi je vous retrouve à
20h très bonne soirée sur antenne